THAT'S WHY HE IS THE KING.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>>> WE WELCOME YOU BACK TO "CBS
THIS MORNING."
AND WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH
NEW PRESSURE ON REPUBLICANS OVER
HOW TO RESPOND TO THE JANUARY
6th ATTACK.
4.5 MONTHS AGO A PRO-TRUMP MOB
STORMED THE CAPITOL, ASSAULTING
POLICE, AND SEEKING TO DISRUPT A
PEACEFUL TRANSITION OF POWER.
LAST NIGHT IN THE HOUSE CHAMBER
WHERE RIOTERS TRIED TO BREAK IN
THIS VERY SAME ROOM, 217
DEMOCRATS AND 35 REPUBLICANS
VOTED TO FORM AN INDEPENDENT
BIPARTISAN COMMISSION TO
INVESTIGATE WHAT HAPPENED.
>> GOP CONGRESSIONAL LEADERS
KEVIN McCARTHY AND MITCH
McCONNELL OPPOSE IT, ALONG WITH
THE VAST MAJORITY OF
REPUBLICANS.
NIKOLE KILLION IS ON CAPITOL
HILL.
GOOD MORNING.
>> Reporter: GOOD MORNING,
ANTHONY.
KEVIN McCARTHY SAYS THAT HE IS
NOT CONCERNED ABOUT THE VOTE,
ALTHOUGH LAST NIGHT HE WAS
WATCHING FROM THE BACK OF THE
HOUSE CHAMBER AS NEARLY THREE
DOZEN PARTY MEMBERS BROKE RANKS
WITH HIM TO SUPPORT THE JANUARY
6th BILL.
>> THE BILL IS PASSED.
>> Reporter: DEMOCRATS CHEERED
THE PASSAGE OF A BIPARTISAN BILL
TO ESTABLISH A JANUARY 6th
COMMISSION.
THE TEN-MEMBER PANEL WOULD BE
EQUALLY DIVIDED BETWEEN
APPOINTED DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS WITH SUBPOENA POWER.
TO EXAMINE THE ROOT CAUSES OF
THE CAPITOL ATTACK.
A FRAMEWORK AGREED TO BY THE TOP
REPUBLICAN ON THE HOUSE HOMELAND
SECURITY COMMITTEE.
>> THIS IS ABOUT FACTS.
IT'S NOT PARTISAN POLITICS.
>> Reporter: STILL, 175
REPUBLICANS VOTED AGAINST THE
COMMISSION.
>> WE HAVE PEOPLE SCALING THE
CAPITOL, HITTING THE CAPITOL
POLICE WITH LEAD PIPES ACROSS
THE HEAD, AND WE CAN'T GET
BIPARTISANSHIP.
>> Reporter: THE BILL NOW FACES
AN UPHILL BATTLE IN THE SENATE
WHERE SENATE MINORITY LEADER
MITCH McCONNELL ECHOED HOUSE
MINORITY LEADER KEVIN McCARTHY
IN OPPOSING THE COMMISSION
DESPITE BEING INVOLVED IN THE
NEGOTIATIONS.
>> HOUSE DEMOCRATS HAVE HANDLED
THIS PROPOSAL IN PARTISAN BAD
FAITH.
>> Reporter: DEMOCRATS HAVE TO
CONVINCE AT LEAST TEN
REPUBLICANS TO SIGN ON WITH SOME
ALREADY CALLING FOR CHANGES.
>> NEED TO DISCUSS WHETHER WE
SHOULD LOOK AT VIOLENT DOMESTIC
EXTREMISM ON BOTH SIDES.
>> Reporter: THE FAMILY OF
FALLEN U.S. CAPITOL POLICE
OFFICER HOWIE LEBENGOOD WHO DIED
BY SUICIDE AFTER THE RIOT
ENDORSED THE COMMISSION WRITING,
"EVERY OFFICER WHO WORKED THAT
DAY AS WELL AS THEIR FAMILIES
SHOULD HAVE A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT HAPPENED."
THE APPEAL COMES AS THE FBI
RELEASED TWO NEW VIDEOS TO
IDENTIFY SUSPECTS WHO ATTACKED
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
[ SHOUTING ]
TODAY THE HOUSE WILL HOLD
ANOTHER VOTE ON A $1.9 BILLION
SECURITY PACKAGE.
IT WOULD PROVIDE MORE FUNDING
FOR THE CAPITOL POLICE AND
RE